GET IT ON AND THEY'LL GET IT ON
AGAIN TOMORROW AS IT'S A  ON TH
GOAL LINE.
THEY SCORED!
THE PUCK YET.
THE NET'S NOT UP YET.
THE PUCK
HINOSTROZA GOT IT BACK TO THE
POINT. AGAIN.
THAT ONE IS SPEARED BY THEP THR
MIDDLE.
SEE ALL THREE SABRES KIND OF
FIXATED ON THE PUCK, NOT S SO D.
JUST ADDING TO IT.
NOW ACROSS ICE.
MITTELSTADT DOES NOT
>> Referee: PHILADELPHIA 6 MINOR
PENALTY
FACE-OFF.
AND WIN THE DRAW BACK TO THE
POININzor: I THINK JONES KNEW IT
WAS LAYAY NET.
HE SCORES!
FATHER'S DAY
OKPOSO, WIDE OPEN ON THE RIGHT
SIDE.
MAKES A BEAUTIFUL PASS ACROSS
NOBODY CAN TAKE IT OUT OF THE
PLAY.
A BEAUTIFUL PET
IT T ONE HERE, INTERCEPTS AND BS
IT BACK.
GETTING BODY
HINOSTROZA THIS FLYERS TEAM IN N
ZONE, THEY WILL TURN THE PUCK
OVER. HE
SCORES!
TAGE THOMPSON FINDSE.
HERE'S DAHLIN IN THE TALKED WE
CIRCLE A COUPLE OF TIMES.
HE JUST GOT BOOTED
WISH.
>> Rayzor: THE P GOES OFF THE
BACK WALL.
THEY BY
CLEARING IT BACK
>> Rayzor: TAKE